I'd ask for beat I'd ask for a block and
I develop a network of about a thousand
people to help me do both of them and I
talked my newspaper editor into defining
my job as producing content but also
connections on the web that can yield
important work in the paper and so my
beat would be based online and it would
also produce pieces for the paper and I
would go about collecting my network of
people to help me do my job well that
approach the approach i would recommend
for a beat reporter right at midwestern
daily newspaper is pro-am it's
professionals working with networks of
amateur contributors who have reason to
join in a search for truth than a search
for facts and better reporting it might
be a network of local bloggers that's
helping you keep your eye on the public
schools for example it's neither
professional journalism the old way
which is a closed system nor simply
citizens doing the best they can to
report on things here and there it's an
attempt to find the hybrid forms that
might work best
well each of these terms helps us notice
something else something different so we
don't need to throw any of them out and
we don't need to equate them either open
source software is partly based on the
idea that thousands of contributors are
better than one thousands of eyes and
ears and programming minds can actually
do a better job than a small team of
closeted professional and so that spirit
taken over into journalism is an
important thing ProAm journalism is an
attempt to find a regular means of
production that draws on the strengths
of both discipline professional
journalists and knowledgeable amateur
and I think we're at the beginning of
understanding how to do that well
there's plenty of examples of reporters
who using simple tools like blogging the
social networking and Twitter and other
new extensions of their hours are
beginning to tap into knowledgeable
outsiders to do their work and learning
the benefits of operating that way Kent
Fisher who is a Dallas Public Schools
reporter for the Dallas Morning News has
a blog that's beginning to operate like
a network in that it can react to things
that he's learned and tell him that's a
big change in the grading policy you
should do a story on that and magically
story appears so there are reporters who
are starting to realize that Dan Gilmore
my friend who used to be a technology
report of the San Jose Mercury News was
right when he said my readers know more
than I do
that's always been true that was true in
the 1950s what's different now is that
the costs for that distributed knowledge
to come together and begin to inform a
reporter's work has been lowered so
dramatically that my readers know more
than I do is now a method for succeeding
in journalism whereas before it would
have been a nice idea but impractical